they fit a meta regression line to this
data which crossed zero at 500 calories
per day which indicates a deficit of 500
calories per day was predicted to result
in zero change in lean mass deficits
larger than that were predicted to
actually yield a reduction in lean mass
but as you can see from the data if you
look at the the figure if you happen to
pull it up uh
it's kind of like when we talk about
that meta-analysis or the
meta-regression about protein intake by
morton and colleagues where it's like we
can identify a break point but when you
look at the individual data points you
do not see
a dramatic area where numbers just fall
off a cliff like it's not like everybody
was doing just fine and then they hit
500 calories per day and you know lean
mass gains tanked there's definitely a
relationship here as the deficit gets
bigger lean mass changes
are harder and harder to come by and so
what that means is if you're trying to
achieve recomposition you want to keep
that general relationship in mind you
don't want to use that 500 number as a
law of physics you know it because that
would be just not at all reflective of
the certainty of that number um but you
definitely want to keep in mind the fact
that
if you're trying to build muscle while
you're losing fat you're going to be in
an energy deficit and the larger that
deficit gets the more challenging it
becomes to kind of thread that needle
and achieve appreciable increases in
lean mass while you're achieving that
fat loss along the way so
ultimately my conclusion after looking
at this meta-analysis and some
some of the related research is uh
recomposition is certainly possible uh
and for a lot of people probably more
than you think it is a feasible goal
and it
you are making some degree of sacrifice
when you set out to do recomposition
you're kind of
accepting on the front end yeah i
probably could gain lean mass faster if
i were
in neutral or positive energy balance
but what you're trying to do there is
you know kind of find that sweet spot
where you're gaining lean mass at a rate
that you're still happy with while also
losing fat mass along the way it can be
a very conv convenient and very time
efficient way to make some pretty
dramatic body composition change without
having to feel like you are fully locked
into one route versus the other
um so
if you check out the article you'll see
that in the there's kind of a practical
application section where i go into
detail about
how you would adjust energy balance for
a variety of different goals
and the way that i tried to quantify
that i think the most
straightforward and simple way to
quantify that
navigation of energy balance or the
manipulation of energy balance is just
by looking at change in body mass so the
rate of weekly or monthly weight gain or
the rate of weekly or monthly weight
loss you know i think that's the easiest
way to look at it and i don't want to go
through and read every possible
permutation here because the most likely
scenario is i'll just get some numbers
jumbled and then cause more confusion uh
so to to get a look at it so i go
through in detail how would you adjust
your rate of weight gain or rate of uh
rate of weight loss if you're training
specifically for strength or
specifically for recomposition or
specifically for hypertrophy or
specifically for fat loss and so there
are some slightly uh different
guidelines for each of those different
scenarios
and i also
in the process of giving those
guidelines i address the fact that your
training age or or your relative
training status is an important factor
that modifies how quickly you want to
gain or lose some weight so
if you have an opportunity i definitely
recommend that you check out that
article to get some of that
[Music]
kind of goal specific advice about what
rate of weight loss or rate of weight
gain would be right for you based on
what you're trying to achieve
but but the general kind of take home
point is
a lot of people say that recomposition
is either impossible or just simply not
feasible and for a large percentage of
lifters i think that that's simply not
true i think it is possible and indeed
is actually feasible um it's especially
true
if you've got plenty of body fat to lose
and you're relatively untrained in that
situation
there's a very high likelihood that you
can get in an energy deficit that is
large enough to get the ball rolling in
terms of fat loss without dramatically
impairing your ability to get stronger
or build muscle
now if you are shredded you're near your
genetic ceiling in terms of strength and
muscularity in that situation
i i will concede that you know dramatic
recomposition is probably a bit of a
long shot